So I'm going to start by taking my total amount of money and splitting it into
fifths. Notice that 1 whole circle is 5 5ths. I'm going to save 2 5ths of my
money, so let's show that on a another circle. And I'm going to save 2 5ths of
my total money. I don't know how much total money I have but I know I'm saving
this fraction. Money.
I'm trying to figure out what fraction I have left that I can still spend.
Visually, I can see that I still have 3 5ths of my money to spend. So how did I
get that? I did 5 5ths, that was the whole amount of money I had, and I need to
subtract off 2 5ths. So I have 5 5ths minus 2 5ths. So I'm taking away 2 5ths
from my 5 5ths. So I just need to subtract the numerators. So 5 5th's take away
2 5th's leaves me with 3 5th's. I work with subtracting just like I do with
adding fractions. I only change the numerators, all I'm doing is taking my 5th's
and taking out two of them, leaving me with 3 5th's. If you got 3 5th's, nice
work. Whether you know it or not, you've already started thinking algebraically.
I have no idea how much money you can earn in a month but we've let that amount
represent this circle. It was an abstract form of reasoning. We knew that if you
saved 2 5ths of it that you would have 3 5ths of it left to spend on whatever
you please. So, even though I don't know the total amount of money, I can still
say at least what fraction of that money can be spent. One of the key skills in
algebra is to find ways to work with unknown amounts or numbers. We'll see this
throughout the entire course.